Stormy Daniels. Welcome to the show.
[inaudible] first of all, you're you're you're in the news again. Uh, how,
how do you feel about this story? Just never going away.
Um, it's getting tiresome. Um,
it just seems like there's always something new coming up. Um,
part of me says I'm ready for it to be over, but the other part of me says like,
I'm going to keep fighting until I get what I want. So what do you want, uh,
to be proven,
not to be a liar for the people that bullied me and broke the law to be
held accountable.
Democrats in Congress. They want to use this story to,
to investigate the president. Would you like to testify in Congress?
Absolutely. Do you think they want to?
Um, I think some do and I think some are afraid that I can't hold
my own, but I definitely can because I have nothing to hide.
If they won't ask you to testify. What, what are your thoughts on that?
Part of me says,
wants to say that I have to trust the legal team and their decisions.
And the other part,
I think we'll always wonder if I was someone different or had a different
profession. If I would be given the opportunity.
You, you had this profession also,
when you met Donald Trump for the first time you met him,
uh, some golf arrangement, the golf tournament. Can you,
can you take us back to the two when you met him alone? At the first time.
It was 2006. It was, uh,
after the golf tournament that day and he asked me to
dinner and I thought it was very funny and I wasn't going to go.
And then I was on the phone with my friend and, uh, he was like,
you have to like what a cool thing to be able to, you know,
pick his brain because he's such a famous businessman at the time.
And he wanted to meet at his hotel and then we were going to go down to
dinner. I assumed. And when I got there,
it was pretty clear that he didn't want to leave the room.
Why was that so clear? Because he was in his pajamas.
What kinds of Gemma's black silk ones.
I see. Yeah. That's not a dinner outfit, that's it? No, nobody else there.
Uh, nobody else was there. He had a bodyguard,
but he stayed outside the room in the hallway. Did you comment on that pajamas?
Of course I did. I made fun of him. I told him, go put some pants on and he did,
he went and got dressed and we started talking and he showed me the room and,
uh, was, began the conversation, very, uh,
conceded talking about himself and I was hungry. So I was a little,
a little angry.
And finally I just had enough of his bragging and put him in his place.
I was like, you're so arrogant. Like,
do you ever ask anybody anything about themselves and he kind.
Of, how does he respond to that? I.
Think he was shocked that someone talked to him like that and he was very taken
back and, uh, he laughed and that's when the whole spanking thing happened.
Of course. And, um.
Spanked him with a magazine with himself on the cover. Yeah. But,
but you insist this was not a sexual?
No, it wasn't. It wasn't at all. He was like, and he was sober. Oh, of course.
Yeah. He doesn't drink at all. Yeah. There was no alcohol.
Did you see from the outside? It's a weird.
But it wasn't sexual after that,
he actually kind of was shocked that I was,
that I had done that and we sat down and had a pretty long conversation.
W what was that about? I mean, where could you meet? Uh.
Tell me about the business, uh, side of the adult business. Like,
did we get royalties? Are there unions? How do we get paid?
Do we get paid by the hour per, like,
it was all very intelligent business conversations.
He was talking about his television show and a vacation. He went on,
it was all very normal stuff. I mean.
So w when did you realize that this was not just a business
meeting?
When I came out of the bathroom and he was taking his clothes off and was on the
bed? I had no warning at all.
What did you feel that just kind of,
I felt at first I was shocked, like genuinely startled.
Cause I didn't expect him to be.
There.
So you just needed to use the bathroom and then you came out and he was on the
bed totally naked. Or though in his underwear.
He was in his underwear. And, uh, and then it was just like, Oh no,
what have I gotten myself into? Because I didn't see it coming at all.
We hadn't discussed it. It wasn't implied.
Nothing. This was the only time you had sex with him, right? Yes.
Did he ever ask you to keep quiet about it? Nope. Did he,
did he talk about his family at all?
Really? Uh, only the first, like 10 minutes. I was in the room.
Like he showed me a picture of his son and I mean, it was very brief.
Like he didn't really talk, he talked about his daughter. Um,
but not after that, never again, like, I even went to meet him at,
at his office in New York.
Like I walked straight through the lobby and they had my name and I've been up
in his office at Trump tower. Like he didn't seem to care. W w w.
What did he say about his daughter? He.
Said that, uh, I think he said that she was starting a clothing company here.
So I spent so long and later when I was talking about being a writer and
director, he told me that I reminded him of her, that I was smart and beautiful.
Like his daughter.
Ivanka? Yes. That's is the problem, but never,
never really worried about millennia? No.
What are your thoughts about millennia? Um, I don't really have any, did,
did you feel, did you have a bad conscience? No.
I wasn't doing anything wrong. I wasn't married.
I don't know what their arrangement was for all.
I know she was into it in 2015.
You signed an NDA that, that,
that should prevent you from sitting here now.
How, why did you do that? First of all.
Initially, a friend of mine, you know, it wasn't a secret, like everybody knew,
like everybody in my life knew, like when it was happening, I used to call,
he used to call it, I put him on speaker phone and we'd make fun of him.
Friends went with me to see him. Like, it was not a secret. Yeah. By.
Then it was only internet as well. It wasn't, yeah, it was.
Everywhere. And it wasn't going to talk about it. It's going to, I mean,
I didn't think anybody cared and a friend of mine who was an attorney
pointed out that if he got the Republican nomination, that I could be in danger,
that, and I was like, what are you talking about? Like, what do you mean?
And he said, well,
you realize you could be driving home right now and being a C and be in a single
car accident. Or you could overdose tonight. I was like,
I don't drive either like exactly.
Or there's a gas leak in your house and it explodes.
And no one will ever think about it, but if it comes out,
then they can't do anything basically. Cause they'll,
it would be too obvious. And then the story came out to get like resurfaced.
And I was offered a bunch of money to go on and tell it, and I didn't want to,
and I didn't want my now,
now I was married and my husband didn't know it.
Not like I hit it. It's just, that happened four years before I even met him.
And do you tell every person you date, who everybody you were with before?
Especially if it was that? No.
So it's hard to find the right timing for that.
Isn't, by the way I did something orange,
like there's no good way to talk about that. Like,
you know, and, uh,
so I remember that they were going to have me on good morning America and
I was very nervous. I was like,
I did not want everybody to know about this because for the record I've been
with way, way hotter celebrities. And I was like,
why couldn't I have been one of them? Like, why does it have to be that one?
And, uh, and then the night before they offered me the NDA or, you know,
and I was like, well, this is perfect because there's an actual record of it.
So they can't kill me. Like nothing bad can happen.
There's a like actual record. And I didn't ask for the money I, to this day.
I always wonder how he came up with that number. Cause.
I mean, no.
I just said whatever. I didn't even question it.
How was the signing done? I mean, was it a car?
It was with just you and your lawyer?
Uh, yeah. And one witness and I was fine with saying nothing.
And then like the story kept like coming up and I just wouldn't say
anything. And then they asked me to lie
and the first statement kind of worded to where it was like,
I didn't have an ongoing affair and I didn't have an affair.
But, but how did they ask you to lie?
Cohen called my attorney and they called me and said,
we need her to sign this statement. And I said,
I wasn't comfortable with doing that. And my attorney was like, well, it's just,
you know, just kind of do this. And I was like, fine. And I did it.
And then a couple of weeks later,
they called again and wanted a more specific statement saying that like,
I never slept with him. I didn't know him. And I was like, I'm not gonna lie.
And they came to my hotel room when I was alone. And they said to me,
you're going to sign this or something bad could happen to your family.
You don't want to be audited. Do you? Who were they? Keith Davidson,
the attorney. And, uh, a man, I didn't know. And the girl who was like,
had kind of put the deal together that I don't work with anymore.
And so I didn't know what to do. So I signed it, but I signed my name wrong,
but it specifically said in the NDA that from that date forward,
they couldn't contact me at all and I couldn't contact them.
And they kept contacting me. They contacted me four times and asked me to lie.
They kept pushing me. And I said, no, you can't do this.
They broke the NDA first. And then Michael Cohen shopped a book. And in the,
um, description of what he was trying to shop it specifically said, Oh,
how I covered the presidents,
but on this and this and this and the $130,000 payment to stormy Daniels.
And I was like, what? Like, I can't defend myself, but he could shop a book.
And I was like, okay, that's strike five. Now I'm going to talk.
That day. When the story broke, how was that for you.
When it first happened? Uh, obviously there were reporters at the door and,
uh, layers,
like news trucks parked out on the street and they were trying to talk to the
neighbors and they were trying to get pictures of my daughter.
So she couldn't go outside and it was all over the news.
So we couldn't turn on the TV. Um,
luckily my daughter was already homeschooled,
so she didn't have to be like taken out of school or anything like that. Um,
so it didn't disrupt her daily, like schooling and stuff like that, um,
in the, you know,
but she couldn't go out and ride her bike and stuff for awhile.
And my neighbors really kind of stepped up and told the press to get out,
get out of there. And like.
Have you tried to explain? Um,
she knows she's she knows she's she knows.
Who the president is. Um,
and it's funny because she recognizes him from home alone too.
Like I was like, wait, what? I totally had forgotten who was in that.
But she was like, Oh, the guy from home alone two is the president.
I was like sad, but true.
I was like, if you only knew how ridiculous is actually. Yeah.
Um, and then she knew,
so she knows that he's the president and she knows that mommy used to know him
and people were very interested about how we used to hang out.
She doesn't know what sex is. So.
He's just a few blocks away. Now,
as we sit here in New York and speak on something,
do do, do you remember that smell? Do you remember this smell old spice?
Was it really?
But what is it? Is it like a, if you met him,
bumped into him on the streets outside here, what would you say to it?
I would just point and laugh. What are you? Yeah.
I mean, I, he was never mean to me. I mean,
he misled me per se, actually. I don't even think he did. I think that, uh,
I think his intentions were actually pretty straight forward. Um,
but yeah, I will also say that.
I think that there's something wrong with him and he's degenerating a bit.
Cause like he can't even see before in complete sentences now.
And I sat and talked to him for three hours and didn't want to jump out of a
window after I spanked him. I mean, after I put him in his place.
Tolerable, but, but he, he wanted you in his show, right?
That was, that was part of his agenda.
So do you think that he wanted to attempt to with that show?
Just show me a little bit, but I think he also saying.
I think he also saw it as an opportunity to like,
cause a stir because that's what he likes to do and be controversial.
How was your life today? Um, interesting.
Uh, are you still working in the same business?
I still work in the adult entertainment business. I still, um, I still stress.
I still dance. Um, I write and direct movies.
I haven't in several months just because I've been so busy and I am getting
older. Obviously 40 is very old porn years.
Like dog years.
I probably died a long time ago and no one told me I'm like the Keith Richards
of porn. So I've had to move on to doing some other things. Um,
obviously I wrote a book which I had been working on for years before this even
happened.
Your book is out in Scandinavia as well. Yes. Thank you so much. So many Daniel.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I
hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.